voici l'avion que les ingénieurs
européens ont dans leurs cartons depuis
dix ans pour succéder à concorde pas de
nom de baptême officiel juste des noms
de code la tsf ou encore perth toujours
la même silhouette de l aile delta
toujours le cockpit avec le nez
basculant mais là s'arrêtent les
comparaisons car cet avion de deuxième
génération contiendrait s'ils étaient
fabriqués l'ensemble des récentes
avancées technologiques et notamment au
niveau des moteurs des réacteurs à cycle
variable capable de développer une
puissance énorme au décollage puis de
passer en régime économique en altitude
de croisière
un avion qui gagnerait en aérodynamisme
et emplois tout en doublant le nombre de
passagers transportés
ce sera un avion qui sera beaucoup plus
performant en terme de consommation il
consommera deux fois moins que quand
cornes il dira deux fois plus loin il
transportera deux fois plus de passagers
et surtout il respectera les normes
d'environnement au vide en vigueur à la
date de son entrée en service américain
ou japonais avec leurs projets d'avenir
grande vitesse restent eux aussi de
fabriquer leur avion supersonique du
futur mais le prix à payer serait énorme
plus de 100 milliards de francs
d'investissements pour un marché de 1000
appareils
la réalité sera sans doute moins
spectaculaire car plus économique avec
le nouvel airbus appelé pour le moment à
3 xx à l'intérieur six en place un avion
qui volera en subsonic sous la vitesse
du son tout comme les nouvelles versions
attendue du boeing 747 rallongé à moins
que les recherches pour la fusée ariane
5 trouvent des applications dans
l'aviation civile
on peut extrapoler et s'acheminer vers
quelque chose qui n'est plus le
successeur de concorde dans l'explosion
classique du terme mais quelque chose
qui est bien plus ambitieux encore qui
seraient parues new york en 80 minutes
en vol sub orbital
un autre projet est à l'étude l'ale
volante imaginé par les français cette
fois pour transporter 1000 passagers à
800 kilomètres heure